well several things one we look
historically the greatest advances have
been made in medicine in the last 50
years and the drugs which we have great
pride in because they really help
patients other 30 drugs that are being
abused by athletes if we look forward we
will continue to develop new drugs and
new technologies and there's no question
that we already know factually that
there are those who are already trying
to get a hold of the new technologies
now when isolated from medical school we
didn't have diuretics we don't check
people with mercury who sounds kind of
wild that wasn't that long ago we had
very limited number of antibiotics and
if you need it or get somebody's blood
count up you had to give them a lot of
transfusions things have changed
dramatically
well if we take several of those changes
and see what's happened for example for
years people took anabolic steroids
because they had anemia for a variety of
courses get their red cells over well we
realized that if you can give them a
substance called EPO erythropoietin you
can stimulate somebody's bone marrow to
make more red cells and so to be a
decreased need for transfusions and so a
pill was developed now it turns out as
one can anticipate EPO was immediately
abused in fact I reported an epidemic of
deaths in four Scandinavian countries
and two sports and a sport called
orienteering and cycling and it turned
out all these deaths occurred right
after Ipoh was introduced into Europe
and although I can never prove it all
the evidence suggests it was probably
related to EPO now EPO typically for
patient
would be injected daily however we
recognize or several times a week at
least we recognize that if we can get a
form of EPO then a lasted longer need
less injections well sure enough we
develop that and comes along in the
Olympic Games in Salt Lake and only
family the people are abusing the
long-acting EPO now there's technology
being developed so that you wouldn't
have to inject the EPO at all but
there's Dean therapy technologies rub a
cream on it can turn on a switch in your
body to make your own EPO and then turn
it off by removing the cream and you
know we know that's probably not too far
down the road just like in many other
forms of therapies we try to make it
easy easy for patients and so that's a
good example of that kind of technology
now human growth hormones a whole other
story human growth hormone prior to the
mid 1980s for people who really needed
enough tell you in a second who needs
some things but people who needed human
growth hormone they were dependent on
grinding up pituitary glands of cadavers
well it turns out that these cadavers in
many cases contain a virus and produces
it produced a disease called Jakob
kreutzfeld disease which is like a kin
to an Alzheimer's dementia well so
obviously but can be used clinically
because some of the athletes were using
it well but with the development of
recombinant DNA technology the same kind
of technology we use to develop EPO they
developed a synthetic human growth
hormone and so we now are able to treat
patients with human growth hormone
safely but as you can expect human
growth hormone is now become one of the
mainstays of doping now if it turns out
you are
deficiency is a child you'll never reach
it with normal growth status we treat
those individuals people with end-stage
AIDS wasting disease we use human growth
hormone to treat those people then
there's a people who are adults who need
to have to get to legally be treated
need to have an absolute deficiency a
growth hormone because the pituitary
gland isn't working because of either
tumor radiation surgery trauma or
hemorrhage in the area whatever it might
be in fact it's the only drug I know of
which you cannot use for off-label
purposes that is you can only use it for
the reason it was approved and it
requires the approval of the Secretary
of Health and Human Services
that's how tightly regulated human
growth Roman hormone is in the United
States but that's another example of
sort of more primitive technology be
replaced by sophisticated technology and
then finding that athletes have been
trying to do so